Democrats are hoping for a blue wave in
the midterms two weeks from today the
podcast pod save America hosted by for
Obama administration alums is hitting
the campaign trail with a new HBO
four-part special since the podcast
launched in 2017 it's been downloaded
more than 330 million times two of the
hosts Jon Favreau and Dan Pfeiffer join
us John served as President Barack
Obama's head speechwriter and Dan was
the former president's communications
director and then senior advisor good
morning to you both good morning so we
know what the president wants to talk
about in the last two weeks you know we
do meaning president Trump yes yes
president Trump we know that so to the
extent that Democrats can have a message
what should it be in the last two months
I think it's very simple it is that if
Republicans keep power they will take
away people's health care and cut
Medicare to pay for tax cuts for
billionaires we have to say that in
every single opportunity are Democrats
saying that it is I actually think they
are I think that when you cut through
the noise that's in the news and on
Twitter you look at the ads when people
are saying us up that's what they're
saying but isn't that kind of where we
were two years ago where Democrats are
focused on health care and that
Republicans are going to take your
health where away and Republicans were
focused on immigration in the wall and
look the one well the difference is now
people have seen that Republicans
actually did try to take their health
insurance away and so we remember what
happened in 2017 and they're basically
promising Mitch McConnell said it the
other week that if they went again they
will now have the votes
because John McCain isn't there anymore
to repeal the Affordable Care Act and
it's gonna happen should Democrats be
worried about the president's approval
rating going up we should be worried
about everything all the time nothing
not fair enough it is the number-one
issue by a lot actually not immigration
it's health care it's shown up people
are worried about it because they see
their premiums rising they see even
though they were guaranteed some
preventative care coverage that their
bills come back and they hadn't asked to
pay for things even though they're
supposed to be covered under Obama care
it's an issue and Republicans know that
it's an issue which is why they're
running ads lying about their position
on pre-existing conditions they're
pretending that they want to protect
previously you were specifically
referring to the governor of Wisconsin a
whole bunch of yeah yes never got walks
in any general of MS
they're all pretending they're for
pre-existing conditions now ever say
after saying that the Affordable Care
Act was horrible and they wanted to
repeal it forever well they've always
been for pre-existing conditions it's
just a men able to get legislation that
will guarantee that they'll be protected
that would replace the Affordable Care
Act and theirs they have no plan to do
that they've never had a plan to do
they've been promising that since Barack
Obama got in office and Roy was a while
ago and many of them are supporting a
lawsuit to destroy pre-existing
condition protections which is a weird
way of supporting them I think everybody
on both sides agree that the political
tone has gotten so mean and so nasty on
both sides so what are you all doing on
your show to bring us all together
I'd say that was my tongue planted in my
cheek yeah because are you worried are
you worried about the tone of your show
adding to the divisiveness because I
watched the first show lot of f-bombs
and I'm okay with an f-bomb but there
were a lot I was thinking about your
mother-in-law Dan if the only problem
with the other side with Republicans
dropping f-bombs we live in such a
different country yeah well I mean it's
about their lives it's about their
racial divisive nests and like what we
try to do on the pot is we're obviously
liberal we have some fun we say what's
on our mind but we try to be factual
when we're not factual we try to correct
it and we try to reach out to people
who've never voted before we don't
usually vote and we get that all the
time people come up to us and say I was
independent I wasn't involved in
politics I was a Republican and now
because you guys told me to go phonebank
knock on doors now I'm doing that for
the first time but save it man we are so
fortunate to have this platform on HBO
with our podcasts and what we use it
even though sometimes we get over
exuberant our language is to encourage
people who were concerned by what's
happening this country to take action
and then tell them how to do it and that
is what we do every day and I think can
encouraging people to to be citizens is
the opposite of contribute to
polarization he's trying to make this a
better democracy we saw your former boss
President Obama yesterday on the
campaign trail in Las Vegas there had
been some
outcry for him to be speaking out sooner
than now should he have been speaking
out sooner than he is already no I think
I think he is out there doing he will
always want to speak when he have the
most impact and that is why he is out
there campaigning if Barack Obama just
going out and giving a speech six months
ago or a year ago the idea that that
would somehow change the policy in this
country I think it's naive what the only
way to change what is happening in the
Trump administration be concerned about
is
elect more Democrats to Congress and he
is out there campaigning in Wisconsin in
Virginia in Nevada to elect Democrats
that's the thing he can do it's a thing
all of us can do to change the direction
of the country do you think the party's
going through a crisis the Democratic
Party an identity crisis right now no no
really I think there's I mean I think
when a party loses and a party's out of
power for a while there's a lot of
soul-searching and debate about where
the party goes from here but I say if
you if you looked across the primaries
we had a lot of contested heated
primaries but everyone came out on the
other side and the party is pretty
United and wanting to go vote and and
you know have a check against Donald
Trump right now we've got a lot of
things to figure out what we're united
against Trump and that's important all
right Jon Favreau Dan Pfeiffer thanks so
much and graduate thanks a lot yeah nice
to see you Kyle as dad there's a new
baby at his house yeah very excited the
news is complete this
[Laughter]